[Musica]
nella vita faccio l'inviato una volta si
usava spesso l'aggettivo speciale
forse perché allora lo erano davvero e
penso a grandi inviati come richard
kapuscinsky ettore mo tiziano terzani
gente che ha scritto articoli da tutto
il mondo e che hanno ispirato anche la
mia carriera sognando un giorno di poter
ripercorrere quella strada
io però non pensavo di poter riuscire a
diventare un inviato e questo per un
blocco emotivo che ho fin da piccolo
durante questo discorso presente la mia
voce potrebbe farci affannata potrei
aver difficoltà di esprimermi per un
groppo alla gola
oppure in altre occasioni cominciò a
sfidare quando succede questo riesco a
farmi il bagno completamente nei miei
vestiti in due minuti non c'è strategia
o camicia scura che tenga succede quando
mi trovo al centro dell'attenzione o in
situazioni di forte stress o disagio
come questa o molto spesso quando capita
ad un giornalista televisivo e quindi
non è proprio il massimo della vita ecco
la svolta è arrivata nel 2011
lavoravo a firenze sono entrato in rai
nel 2008 per concorso
il caporedattore viene da me mi dice
gianmarco vai a vedere cosa sta
succedendo in lunigiana nel nord della
toscana c'è un allagamento dei nubifragi
ovviamente non sapeva che cosa lei avrei
trovato sul posto perché non avrebbe
mandato maker o l'ultimo arrivato il più
giovane
sta di fatto che arrivò ad aulla
lunigiana al mattino e la situazione ben
diversa da quella che avevamo immaginato
c'è la devastazione c'erano morti
c'erano di esperti c'erano tre ponti
crollati i ponti e poi ne riparleremo
io comincio a fare il mio lavoro da
cronista finalmente su un fatto di
cronaca importante raccolgo
testimonianze interviste
rimarrò lì per più di dieci giorni con
la stessa camicia allo stesso
giubbottino di pelle la mattina faceva
molto freddo perderò anche la voce ma
questo è un altro discorso che ha a che
fare con la vita di noi inviati
quello che mi interessa sottolineare
quello che succederà quella sera stessa
alle 20 in punto mi trovo di fronte ad
una telecamera
quella è l'edizione delle 20 del tg1 il
tg1 delle 20 è l'edizione più vista in
italia sono 45 milioni di italiani che
aspettano di sapere cosa gli racconterei
ovviamente ero molto
nervoso molto sotto stress la telecamera
si accende e cominciò a parlare la mia
voce però è calma riesco ad esprimermi
non sudo forse era abbastanza freddo era
a fine ottobre comunque riesco a portare
al termine quella diretta di un minuto e
mezzo riesco a raccontare tutto quello
che avevo visto durante quella lunga
giornata alla fine di quella diretta
mi rendo conto che potevo fare l'inviato
avrei convissuto per sempre con questo
problema ma ce la potevo fare ma perché
intestardirsi tanto nel voler fare un
qualcosa che mi creava così grossi
problemi perché penso che raccontare le
storie delle persone raccontare la vita
della gente e raccontare il mondo sia
una delle cose più belle e più
importanti che si possano fare e molto
spesso il giornalismo a differenza delle
alluvioni che i ponti le distrugge a
volte molto spesso il giornalismo i
pontili può anche creare e ora vi spiego
come maggio 2019 scusate maggio 2019
mi trovo a caracas in venezuela inviato
per la rai per seguire i fatti che
stavano avvenendo nel paese
un giorno vengo a conoscere una vicenda
che riguarda interessa 64 bambini 64
bambini veneziani che hanno bisogno di
cure
purtroppo però quelle cure vengono
rimandate da circa tre settimane questo
per effetto di un accordo che c'era tra
il governo venezuelano è un ospedale
italiano che prevedeva il trasferimento
di questi bambini proprio in italia
quell'ospedale era il bambin gesù di
roma
purtroppo però il governo venezuelano
non stava pagando quei milioni di euro
necessari al trasferimento di questi
bambini che non potevano essere curati
però nel loro paese per la mancanza
delle medicine e dei trattamenti
necessari
decido quindi di andare a casa di maria
kurjo maria kurjo a sette anni e di
caracas ed è una delle bambine appunto
che attendevano queste cure non più
rimandabili l'incontro sua madre in una
casa molto povere ad un quartiere
molto povero di caracas la madre in
quell'occasione fa un appello agli
italiani ma al mondo disperato in
lacrime chiedendo di sbloccare
finalmente quella situazione ovviamente
io realizzo il servizio che poi quella
sera stessa entrerà nelle case degli
italiani con l'appello della madre di
maria kurjo poche ore dopo il bambin
gesù di roma organizza una conferenza
stampa per annunciare che dell'età lì a
poco avrebbe consentito il trasferimento
di questi bambini in italia per
finalmente effettuare queste cure lo
avrebbe fatto gratuitamente pro bono
ovviamente mi precipito subito a casa
della madre di maria kurjo dove si
trovava anche un'altra madre di un altro
bambino anche lui affetto da leucemia e
quindi anche lui in attesa di queste
cure don loro la notizia ovviamente loro
non lo sapevano e questa volta la loro
reazione o un pianto ma di gioia di
grande felicità
ricordo quel momento come uno dei
momenti più belli della mia vita
purtroppo vero sapere tre giorni dopo
che il bambino dell'altra signora non ce
la farà nell'attesa di quel
trasferimento in italia invece maria
kurjo e tanti altri bambini veneziani
riusciranno ad ottenere quelle cure
riusciranno quindi a salvarsi
ecco questo è uno degli esempi in quel
giornalismo diventa un ponte tra gli
ultimi tra gli inascoltati
tra chi non avrebbe altra possibilità
per far sentire la propria voce e chi
invece quel potere di risolvere le
situazioni cela i politici le
associazioni le singole persone facciamo
adesso un passo indietro e andiamo nel
gennaio del 2017 mi trovavo questa volta
inviato sempre per la rai
ma in italia a teramo sono in compagnia
di un collega giorgio specchia del
giornale radio della rai ci troviamo a
cena siamo lì per l'emergenza neve
stanno trascorrendo alcuni giorni
facendo cronaca appunto in abruzzo
a un certo punto notiamo un tweet del
presidente della provincia di pescara un
tweet confuso che parla di morte di
possibili dispersi di un una valanga e
di un hotel
noi non sappiamo che fare decidiamo però
di andare a vedere sul posto cosa stava
succedendo ci mettiamo in auto e
arriviamo a
un piccolo paesello sotto il gran sasso
attorno a mezzanotte il paese
completamente immerso nel buio c'è un
black out ci sono tre metri di neve è
l'unica luce è in fondo ed è la luce del
centro di coordinamento della protezione
civile ci avviciniamo chiediamo
informazioni ci confermano che una
spedizione è appena partita su degli sci
dei soccorritori si sono messi sugli sci
e stanno cercando di raggiungere un
albergo che si trova a qualche
chilometro più a monte rispetto a dove
ci troviamo quello tel
quell albergo e ovviamente l'hotel
ricopiarlo e queste sono le immagini che
ovviamente voi tutti riconoscete
da allora era mezzanotte cominciamo
quindi a lavorare ea dare informazioni
su quella vicenda
io avevo la prima edizione al mattino
giorgio invece andava in onda sul
giornale radio della rai ogni mezz'ora e
quindi faceva la spola tra il certo di
coordinamento della protezione civile e
il mio collega dandogli le informazioni
su dove si trovasse che soccorse eravamo
gli unici giornalisti ma soltanto perché
ci trovavamo vicini quando avevamo avuto
questa notizia gli altri sarebbero
arrivati al mattino quel che succederà
dopo lo conoscete tutti
purtroppo i dispersi salvati sotto la
valanga quei quattro bambini tratti in
salvo ma anche le vittime poi le
polemiche il processo ancora in corso ma
non è questo che voglio sottolineare in
questa occasione ma è quello che
succederà tre settimane dopo mi trovavo
a roma l'emergenza era finita stavo
facendo colazione alla mattina apre il
giornale sfogliandolo trovo l'intervista
a fabio fabio salsetta fabio salsetta è
uno dei due sopravvissuti di rigopiano
che si trovava al di fuori dell'hotel
nel momento della valanga
lui si era salvato casualmente in
quell'occasione racconta in
quell'intervista a quelle ore di
disperazione tra il momento della
valanga e l'arrivo dei soccorsi
mi trovavo in auto racconta fabio
assieme ad un altro sopravvissuto
avevamo freddo era meno dieci meno 12
gradi eravamo disperati era tutto buio
non vedevamo niente non sapevamo dove
fossero gli altri soprattutto non
sapevamo se qualcuno sarebbe
effettivamente è venuto a soccorrerci a
un certo punto accendiamo la radio e
sentiamo una voce quella voce era la
voce di giorgio specchia del collega
il giornale radio continua fabio e
grazie a quella radiocronaca di mezz'ora
in mezz'ora noi avevamo la certezza che
qualcuno sapeva che noi eravamo qua che
qualche soccorritore stava cercando di
raggiungerci i soccorritori sono a 3 km
dall'hotel i soccorritori sono due
chilometri dall'hotel
i soccorritori sono quasi arrivati e
fabio conclude probabilmente quella voce
ci ha dato quella forza e quella
speranza necessaria per non soccombere
alla disperazione
ecco anche in questo caso il giornalismo
può diventare un ponte un collegamento
tra i soccorritori soccorsi tra chi sta
cercando un aiuto e chi quell'aiuto
effettivamente lo potrà portare potrei
continuare a lungo e raccontando
aneddoti di questo tipo ma purtroppo il
tempo è quasi finito mi lascio un
momento per rivolgermi direttamente e
soprattutto ai più giovani presenti qui
in sale non solo non rinunciate mai ai
vostri sogni
cercate sempre di raggiungere il vostro
obiettivo della vita anche se dovesse
costare un bagno completo nei vostri
vestiti o molto molto peggio
vi lascio con un brano tratto da una
serie di articoli contenuti in un libro
che si chiama dispacci dalla cambogia
un giorno mi imbatto in un check point
man rossi uno dei soldati mi vede
comincia a correre verso di me era fuori
di sé aree invasato mi sbatte contro il
muro mi [ __ ] una pistola dentro la gola
e lo guardo con gli occhi spalancati e
penso questo è il momento in cui morirò
poi non so perché improvvisamente senza
motivo cominciò a ridere
una risata a crepapelle sguaiata quella
risata ne salverà la vita perché il
soldato avrà un attimo d'esitazione
necessario affinché il capitano del suo
battaglione si avvicini e blocchi
quell'esecuzione questo era tiziano
terzani un inviato molto ma molto
speciale grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]